I don't know how else to describe it,
but the joy is seeing it finished.
The joy is seeing people using the
building,
seeing them,
enjoying being there,
seeing their response to the uniqueness
of the place.
We have many projects here that are
extraordinary.
Drawings had beautiful models,
but they're not realize,
and for me that's the saddest thing
because the joy is the realization
struggle is getting it realized.
The struggle was dealing with a myriad
of people that sometimes come and go
during the building process.
I've been involved in many,
many projects were the only person who's
there from the beginning to the end is
the architect of the people who have
prominent positions in decisions that
are made aren't there to see what those
decisions cause and how they affect what
is fine.
Maryville.